the people of Colombia who voted against
the agreement with the Revolutionary
Armed Forces of Colombia owned by the
Spanish initials FARC aren't rejecting
peace in favouring war the government of
Juan Manuel Santos negotiated with the
terrorists for four years in Cuba and
came up with a series of agreements
where they would lay down their arms it
would be gradually reintegrated in
society colombian people considered the
details of the plan the fact that the
guerillas would submit themselves to
some sort of ad hoc tribunals rather
than the normal judicial system they
would be accorded seats
almost immediately in the colombian
Congress and so you have people who are
considering all of the damage done the
murders the killing the mayhem meted out
by the FARC and now these people are
going to find their way into the
Congress instead of going to jail so now
we go back to the drawing board and
negotiate new terms by which the
guerillas will lay down their arms and
be reintegrated in Colombian society do
you think Colombians made the right call
and rejecting this peace deal let us
know in the comments section and let us
know what other topics you want a EEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds